to be in the top three of the movie
chosen that is surreal because we were
just having fun at first and now of f is
being cast on the other side of the
world to win the price it's like having
birthsday and Christmas on one day it's
very important when you're doing movie
to share feelings with people I think
that's what we want as it's really nice
to see that our movie is watched by
everyone Everyone likes being invited at
the Academy receiving an award it's a
great opportunity for ourselves we
already had a lot of people asking to
watch the film after they saw the
announcement the person who has inspired
me the most from previous Student
Academy Awards is Asher jalinski with
Miller and Son their presence is amazing
and they inspired me to apply to the
Student Academy Award
a film that were last year the ostrich
told me the world is fake and I think I
believe it which was just amazing and
then this year to be in that same
category is really special his name is
Shu because his vision of capturing
people's relationships and intimacy it's
wonderful I really admire previous
winners like spele the right thing was
the first film I watched in my first
film class in college and since then
I've been a byan Robert seis VAR is this
earnestness in his work and love for the
characters he portrays regardless of
shre doctor because we all saw this work
when we are students and even when we
are I would like to name someone from
our school definitely IL chatak not only
his graduation film was a big
inspiration but also his career right
now I really admire Laura Zine with her
film making waves I was really inspired
by her subject in her documentary so I'd
love to give a shout out to who the same
school as us their f with really be
amazing but a great subject and really
gives motion to work worship so Props to
them